Centrale de Paris alors présente sont
embouteillées lui aussi par ce
fréquemment des accidents et il
travaillait dans les conditions que nous
travaillons c'est France nous pouvons
dire que c'est inhumain
[Musique]
1h25 du matin garde vos Girard dans le
silence de la nuit une rame entre en
gare
pourquoi cette précipitation
ce tracteur qui s'accroche
ce wagon disparaissant dans la nuit à
travers Paris qui sommeille
varie sommeil illusion Paris semble
sommeil Paris est engourdi cette
léthargie n'est qu'apparente
Paris vit la nuit Paris bye le guéparis
mais Paris a également un visage
besogneux c'est précisément dans ce
décor que nous vous emmenons aux Halles
très exactement
les halles centrales de Paris ville de
l'alimentation qui ont reçu de Zola dans
l'un de ses romans les plus connus le
nom évocateur de Ventre de Paris
c'est précisément aux halles du poisson
où nous vous convions hier vers 16h à
Lorient Concarneau Boulogne La Rochelle
Dieppe le poisson rentrait au port
immédiatement emballé transporter soit
par wagon ou camion frigorifique pouvant
tenir des températures jusqu'à - 20
degrés il est dirigé sur Paris
à une heure du matin comme vous venez de
le voir il arrive au Halles poisson de
toutes sortes de toutes provenance
seront mises à disposition des
commerçants détaillants avant 6h heure
de la cloche c'est vers 8h que les
étales des marchés et boutiques vont
être garnis au choix des ménagères c'est
donc un poisson voyageant dans des
conditions d'hygiène et de fraîcheur
maxima que vous trouverez chaque jour
chez votre poissonnier mais les halles
du poisson posent des problèmes avec une
population qui dépasse 8 millions les
tonnages ont augmenté sans cesse il
s'ensuit un encombrement inextricable
aux abords et à l'intérieur de ce marché
le gouvernement ayant décidé depuis 1960
une décentralisation des Halles de Paris
fixait son choix sur Rungis
ce qu'en pense les poissonniers nous
allons le savoir et c'est tout d'abord
avec Monsieur Gerbier président des
mandataires que nous nous sommes
entretenus
puis sur un marché à Colombes où
Monsieur ringette nous parle de ses
problèmes au stade du détail
quelles sont vos problèmes actuels le
principal les principaux c'est la
circulation justement pour arriver de
bonheur au marché et puis alors acheter
avoir plus de temps pour acheter au
Halles voyez-vous que actuellement 1964
comparativement avec les aux années
d'après-guerre on consomme plus de
poissons
je pense que à l'heure actuelle ça
commence à venir oui je crois qu'on en
consomme plus et pour quelle raison la
qualité je suppose à Neuilly enfin où
Monsieur Conty président des détaillants
de la région parisienne expose le point
de vue général de sa corporation
de Paris notamment en pavillon de
poisson donc on reste plus du tout à
l'état du marché
lorsqu'ils ont été créés c'était pour
recevoir environ entre 150 et 200 tonnes
à l'heure actuelle on reçoit tous les
jours
entre 500 et 600 tonnes comme leur
grandeur n'a pas augmenté et bien une
ville de vous dire que nous travaillons
dans des conditions particulièrement
pénible étant donné que il y a toujours
69 postes pour un nombre de poissonniers
qui est multiplié par le facteur 4 ou 5
sur avant-guerre en conséquence
nous pensons que il était inévitable de
voir une modification de ce marché les
halles centrales de Paris alors présente
sont embouteillées mais aussi par ce
fréquemment des accidents et il
travaillait dans les conditions que nous
travaillons c'est France nous pouvons
dire que c'est inhumain nous espérons
que le centrale de Réal de Rungis seront
prévues avec de larges voies d'accès et
des points de d'élargeois de dégagement
parce que étant donné son éloignement il
faudra au poissonnier détaillants ici en
Bron faire très vite pour revenir très
vite à une disposition des consommateurs
[Musique]